did humans really just have a
conversation with a whale news reports
are jumping all over this headline that
scientists had a 20-minute conversation
with a humpback whale named Twain but
how is this possible to try to engage
with a humpback scientists played a
pre-recorded whale call into the sea
through an underwater speaker scientists
hoped that what they played was akin to
a greeting call and to their surprise
the humpback named Twain approached and
circled their boat and started talking
back over the course of 20 minutes Twain
consistently responded to every single
recording that was played in a similar
manner scientists believe that this is
the first time humans and humpback
whales have ever conversed in whale
language however we still don't really
know what was being said in this whale
language using AI scientists hope to one
day crack this language barrier but
until then we can only guess what was
said in this unprecedented conversation